one of the great problems of human
beings is that we're far too good at
keeping going where experts are
surrendering to the demands of the
external world living up to what's
expected of us and getting on with the
priorities as others around us to find
them we keep showing up and being an
excellent boy or girl and we can pull
this magical feat off for up to decades
at a time without so much as an outward
twitch or crack until suddenly one day
much to everyone's surprise including
our own we break the rupture can take
many forms we can no longer get out of
bed we fall into a catatonic depression
we develop all-consuming social anxiety
we refuse to eat we babble incoherently
we lose command over part of our body
we're compelled to do something
extremely scandalous and entirely
contrary to our normal selves we become
wholly paranoid in a given area we
refuse to play by the usual rules in our
relationship we have an affair ramp up
the fighting or otherwise poke a very
large stick into the wheels of
day-to-day life breakdowns are hugely
inconvenient for everyone and so
unsurprisingly there is an immediate
rush to medicalize the problem and
attempt to excise it from the scene so
that business as usual can restart but
this is to misunderstand what's going on
when we break down a breakdown is not
merely a random piece of madness or
malfunction it's a very real albeit very
inarticulate bid for health it is an
attempt by one part of our minds to
force the other into a process of growth
self understanding and self-development
which it has hitherto refused to
undertake if we can put it paradoxically
it's an attempt to jumpstart a process
of getting well properly well through a
stage of falling very ill
the danger therefore if we merely
medicalize a breakdown and attempt to
shift it away at once is that we're
going to miss the lesson embedded within
our sickness a breakdown isn't just a
pain though it is that too of course
it's an extraordinary opportunity to
learn the reason we break down is that
we have not over many years flexed very
much there were things we needed to hear
inside our minds that we deftly put to
one side there were messages we needed
to heed bits of emotional learning and
communicating we didn't do and now after
being patient for so long far too long
the emotional self is attempting to make
itself heard in the only way it now
knows how it has become entirely
desperate and we should understand and
even sympathise with its mute rage what
the breakdown is telling us above
anything else is that it must no longer
be business as usual that things have to
change or and this can be properly
frightening to witness that death might
be preferable why can't we simply listen
to the emotional need calmly and in good
time
and avoid the melodrama of a breakdown
because the conscious mind is inherently
lazy and squeamish and so reluctant to
engage with what the breakdown
eventually has to tell us with brutality
for years it refuses to listen to a
particular sadness or there is a
dysfunction in a relationship we're in
flight from or there are desires we
sweep very far under the proverbial
carpet we can compare the process to a
revolution for years the people press
the government to listen to their
demands and adjust for years the
government makes token gestures but
shuts its ears until one day it's simply
too much for the people who stormed the
palace gates destroy the fine
furnishings and shoot randomly at the
innocent and the guilty mostly in
revolutions there is no good outcome the
legitimate grievances and needs of the
people are not addressed or even
discovered there's an ugly civil war
sometimes literally suicide the same is
true of breakdowns yet a good mental
physician
is hard to listen to rather than censor
the illness they detect within its
oddities a plea for more time for
ourselves for a closer relationship for
a more honest fulfilled way of being for
acceptance of who we really are sexually
that's why we started to drink or to
become reclusive to grow entirely
paranoid or manically seductive a crisis
represents an appetite for growth that
hasn't found another way of expressing
itself many people after a horrific few
months or years of breakdown will say
you know I don't know how I'd ever have
gotten well if I hadn't fallen ill in
the midst of a breakdown we often wonder
whether we have gone mad we have not
we're behaving oddly no doubt but
beneath the surface agitation we are on
a hidden yet logical search for health
we haven't become ill we were ill
already our crisis if we can get through
it is an attempt to dislodge us from a
toxic status quo and it represents an
insistent call to rebuild our lives on a
more authentic and sincere basis
thank you for commenting liking and
subscribing
we also offer books games home wear and
therapy sessions to find out more follow
the link on your screen now